happy wednesday everybody
i'd call it hump day but i don't want to
get your hopes up
so we're learning more about the raid at
mar-a-lago turns out the feds actually
broke into melania's closet
and spent a lot of time in there here
they are leaving
[Music]
those feds are hot
now imagine if they did this to
hillary's closet what do you think they
would find there
true
she's killed more people than alec
baldwin
all it takes is one oh stop it of course
the new angle for the media is the
president raids his opponents home but
it's the republicans who pounce so it's
now you who's the threat forget people
actually trying to kill supreme court
justices or people shooting cops they
prefer the culprit to fit their fantasy
stereotype which often looks like this
that's actually that's not photoshop
tyrus
and so they chase possibilities of
violence based on words from everyday
people reacting to a news event that
shakes up their lives arresting them for
thought crimes can't be far behind which
is something that's literally impossible
for our president to be charged with
[Music]
but remember to them words are the same
as violence meanwhile real violence
burning down a couple of city blocks is
something you had coming
ben collins of nbc actually combed
through pro-trump message boards looking
for danger
not particularly bright people but these
are people who are ready to fight these
are people who are ready to go and
they've proven it in the past and now
they are ready to fight regardless of if
they're being watched by the fbi or not
i would not be surprised if we see the
department of homeland security issues
some kind of bulletin that we are
entering a heightened threat environment
bulletin
oh we're going to hell
meanwhile here's our favorite spy
screwing fart sniffing
dope ranting about election violence
republicans have recognized that they
can no longer win
elections with votes and so they're
leaning in hard to try and win elections
uh with violence and they're fomenting
that violence uh right now this is who
they are now they are a chaos
party
so it's not the raid fomenting violence
it's the reaction to it if swalwell got
any dumber a box of hammers might sue
him for stolen valor
nice beard though meanwhile media listed
pro-trump supporters calling for
political retribution so those people
are now on the radar though i doubt
they'll hit the streets and burn down
affordable housing no they're just
responding to a shocking act against
someone they admire but expressing anger
now makes you a target it's like when
some idiot jumps into a lion cage at the
zoo and this naturally upsets the lion
then they blame the lion for eating off
the idiot's face
that's why i invite kill me to the zoo
so the news
now is rage and in a weird contradiction
the press mocks the anger while
packaging it as deadly but i wonder how
real those messages are i mean they
might be but it's hard to trust anything
from these people i mean how many
informants helped plan the crimes they
were working on it's a good question too
bad no one will ever answer that
did any fbi agents or confidential
informants actively participate in the
events of january 6. yes or no
yes or no sir i can't i can't answer
that did any fbi agents or fbi
informants actively encourage and incite
crimes of violence on january 6th 26th
sir i can't answer that did mr epps urge
them to tear down the barricades similar
to the other answers i cannot answer
that why shouldn't you ask that question
about that in this raid now think about
it remember all those people who
believed trump was an existential threat
the existential scandal that has
surrounded the trump presidency because
he is an existential threat to those
american values an existential threat to
what the country's nature should be an
existential threat to our democracy he
is an existential threat to our nation
and to the globe the existential threat
to the future of the united states he is
an existential threat
to the country they believe is
existential that they need to unseat
president trump
says the expert in getting unseated
oh stop it he's down he's got a new job
he's got a new job and remember all the
comparisons to hitler
we're already dealing with a president
who refers to the press as the enemy of
the people that's language that was used
by adolf hitler america's most poisoned
human beings america's nazis look at
donald trump and see their biggest hero
since adolf hitler there is no
difference from what donald trump is
preaching from what adolf hitler
preached in the early 30s
yes no difference at all apparently
someone better alert trump right away
that he has three jewish grandkids
wow
that is
that is one lousy hitler
you suck as hitler
wow and someone better alert donnie
deutsch that he's still a witness
so
too easy
so if they feel that way why wouldn't
they go above the law to take out the
next existential hitler threat i mean
they did the russia hoax and buried the
laptop story so why not fabricate a
crime again it's your duty if you
believe he's orange hitler and of course
if he's hitler then we're all nazis to
be hunted it's already started the fbi
already tried to inflate the numbers of
domestic terrorists to justify
investigations and then they tried to
define parents at school board meetings
as white supremacists remember trump
supporters being attacked on the streets
people targeted at restaurants it
reminds me of the 2020 movie the hunt
about trump supporters being literally
hunted in the wild by rich libs like
they know how to hunt
but it may be time to reclassify that
movie from horror thriller to
documentary
so what's next if they go after people
on message boards won't that radicalize
more people and create more threats
suddenly everyone to the right of the
view is a threat which if i were the
dems this would worry me you should now
be afraid of your own scare tactics
because what happens when the
republicans gain power
for us it'll be like the first time you
pee after 10 beers
it's gonna feel like amazing
that might be the best feeling ever
[Applause]
applause over urinating
but it's the dems who broke the seal
with the raid
just like 2015 they poked a beast they
mocked a beast then the beast absorbed
all their energy from all those tv spots
on morning joe and devoured the
democrats like stelter eating pizza on a
toilet
and now their trump derangement gave all
of his critics amnesia so they forget
that persecution leads to retribution
it's cause and effect like joe plus coat
equals confusion
so
what goes around comes around until the
only one around is this guy
and it's like they always say the night
is always darkest before the dawn
let's welcome tonight
if laughter's the best medicine then
he's dr kevorkian actor writer comedian
jamie lisa
her films are darker than the one i
leave in my bathtub filmmaker producer
director of the new alex jones
documentary alex lee moyer
[Applause]
like a potato she's usually baked
haley get in fox news contributor cat
tip
and space mountain waits in line to ride
him
a massive sidekick
so jamie it's good to see you um good to
see you i think you need to start
wearing tighter shirts
what do you think i feel like this shirt
is the right size it's my body that's
too big
well there must be some
part of a store that would sell you a
shirt
that would probably give you more room
to move yeah i go to the small and short
men's store yes
i bet you do um as i mean as we all
probably know watch the show regularly
you're mainly a threat to yourself
yeah but given europe it seems like you
could be a threat to this country now
correct do you think so i real quick
pause when you said in the monologue the
peeing after 12 beers yeah i don't know
that there is a better feeling and
[Laughter]
it also helps wake you up in the morning
do you know what i mean get you right
out of bed
um
sad i believe that uh i do believe that
biden did not know the siege was
happening i don't know if other people
agree with that or not i heard uh that
his alibi it was that he was putting his
jacket on for the nine and a half hours
of the scene isn't it crazy how
different biden and trump are couldn't
possibly be more different trump got his
house broken into biden's not even house
broken
[Laughter]
you got one more yeah
i always assume he has three and like he
usually bats two out of three one really
sucks could have been the first kid who
knows here it comes yes
but i did give um
like i sometimes i'll click over to see
what's going on in the other stations
yeah it was just infuriating checking
out cnn but i remember what my dad
always told me he always said
when life gives you don lemon change the
channel
[Laughter]
there's a guy here that just laughs at
everything you say i think i think you
brought him alex welcome to the show so
happy to have you i love your movies oh
thank you so much your first movie which
i always screw up the title because i'm
an old man uh what's the title of the
movie tfw no gf so you know everything
about message sports and also the alex
jones it's a it's a terrific documentary
you don't have to like out shows like
the movie what do you make of the
so-called this this belief in like
violent uh like violent rhetoric on
message boards that's kind of your
wheelhouse
uh i think that in any time that you go
looking for that kind of thing on a
message board you'll be able to find it
yeah so
uh being able to weaponize that at any
moment in a utilitarian way makes a lot
of sense and this is you know the the
democrats their platform is is fear
right now so you know it's right in
their toolbox do you think this helped
trump
uh this
because he's already kind of a folk hero
people are with people were looking at
desantis
and now it's kind of like well no he's
back because and he's back and he's
pissed it's like rambo it's like rambo
thank you they like rambo it's
definitely amazing for his story arc as
if it couldn't get any more interesting
i mean his hero's journey just keeps
getting like weirder and weirder yeah
that's true i i think this i would if i
was your friend i would tell you that's
your next movie
just following trump around uh-huh
well see he'd have to uh the the access
the access might be a problem
but you both have the same color hair
that's true
riveting journalism thank you
i noticed that
i noticed that tyrus yeah you're about
two out of three too sometimes yes
we're like we're like i'm mad about the
space mountain things
more like number two out of three yeah
yeah yeah yeah tyrus what do you think
well i think it's important we need to
remember
to
not respond like this is that we're
being heckled you're being attacked they
threw a jab it wasn't a great jab but it
was annoying like our eyelash got stuck
in her eye kind of a jab
and what i am pleased to see uh
mr president listen to us at all during
when he was running against you and we
said stop beating up the old guy they're
feeling bad for him and he would come
out and he would fight me
he had a private meeting
so proud of him he didn't get involved
if you don't respond they need the
response they need
somebody to burn something down they
need us to fall and play their game
our response will be at the ballot box
that's where we need to respond
they're not going to get january 6 2 no
matter how bad they want it they're not
going to get the red maga hats to go
burn down a building or destroy a city
because most of us work in these cities
and we have to keep our economy going
thanks to the administration so
keep
no no response is the best response be
the snake at the bottom of the ocean and
let the little punks chew on you and
strike at the ballot box
cat uh uh do you believe we're entering
a heightened threat environment
yeah i mean people are gross on message
boards people say cr if i worried about
what people said about me on message
boards i would never leave the house
because i'd be too scared i was gonna
get hit with a penis
[Laughter]
how do you get hit with a penis
[Applause]
[Laughter]
people have some stuff
they have some thoughts in their head
and then they type them out yeah nobody
knows anything yet really yeah there's
been days of just these fiery fiery hot
takes coming from all over the place
about something we have almost no
information out about but isn't that the
story of our lives i mean with uh if if
we actually waited for the facts we
wouldn't have a show
[Laughter]
sometimes i don't even read the i read
the headline and then i sit down and do
this show no i'm kidding you know i
prepare yeah you have the notes right
there to prove it yes i do
my assistant julio does this yes
r.i.p julio
where are we
oh are we done
i can't see that far hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else